**Susan Daniels**: Welcome back we're still in the morning session of day three, and this is the final segment.
**Susan Daniels**: I do want to pause for a moment and give a shout out to the mentoring team that have been fielding questions, both in the chat and through the Q amp a.
**Susan Daniels**: I want to reinforce that the best place to get any technical questions or questions about accessing materials.
**Susan Daniels**: That is best addressed through the Q amp a That way, you can get a one on one response about your specific situation and what learning platform you're on.
**Susan Daniels**: So please direct Those sort of questions through the Q amp a there's a team ready and waiting to handle those for on specific issues, relative to yourself.
**Susan Daniels**: let's keep and we're doing been doing a great job of keeping the chat to just questions relevant to the arm the content currently under discussion.
**Susan Daniels**: Now um I did see a good question that came through during the break and it had to do with Susan I looked back over the materials for iron triangle didn't see it but saw the talent triangle, and is it the same, and the answer to that is no is not.
**Susan Daniels**: The talent triangle is the kind of professional development units, you need to get in the areas that they've named them on.
**Susan Daniels**: that's more about how to maintain your certification is the talent triangle, the iron triangle i'm not sure it's specifically mentioned in your.
**Susan Daniels**: content that you have it's an, it is a professional expression.
**Susan Daniels**: Is a shorthand or brief way of saying scope schedule and cost, so let me give you an example you're sitting in a meeting.
**Susan Daniels**: And you're trying someone wants to change a requirement or add a requirement or something they're telling you about something.
**Susan Daniels**: And you can go that's going to rock the iron triangle or that's going to have serious impact on the iron triangle, which is just a way of saying that's going to really affect all of the dynamics so.
**Susan Daniels**: it's just a reference that is used in the profession i'm not sure you'll specifically see it in the curriculum so forgive me for just using shop talk um but that's what that is.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: I need yeah i'm guilty it's kind of jargon, my apologies, but every profession has its jargon right and that's one of them over here in North America.
**Susan Daniels**: My apologies, so let me get back to the formal curriculum and we've got an hour before we take a break for lunch okay and we're gonna look at governance and.
**Susan Daniels**: Governance is who you are really use as an asset.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's talk about who they are, and what what their role is okay well, of course, every time they introduce a new task or a new component.
**Susan Daniels**: Of the curriculum they're going to give you this deliverables and tools and i'm basically what it means by stakeholder artifacts are things that you're producing for your stakeholders okay it's reports.
**Susan Daniels**: it's change request forms it's communications from your stakeholders it's it's really things that happened during the course of business, these are considered kind of artifacts of doing your project.
**Susan Daniels**: To be able to manage your arm your stakeholder governance, you of course you're going to use your your your platform for communicating with them.
**Susan Daniels**: Your project management information system okay so see even in the curriculum itself once it introduced it now it's just going to use it as an acronym so.
**Susan Daniels**: pmi is kind of known for that when I see one of these acronyms i'm certainly going to alert you to put it on your acronym list okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So project governance, the people that are working together to help you succeed with this project.
**Susan Daniels**: So what is the role.
**Susan Daniels**: long list of accountabilities isn't it.
**Susan Daniels**: just giving you a moment to think about it and read it.
**Susan Daniels**: But what do I do with this right, what do I do with this checklist.
**Susan Daniels**: All right, so you've you've got your sponsors, these are the people who have spending authority I they're definitely on your governance committee right they definitely are watching and impacted by results right, so they are with authority.
**Susan Daniels**: But you also want to recruit other people to be on your governance list because you need people that are going to champion your project.
**Susan Daniels**: and help you influence people who may or may not be willing to give you the subject matter expert, you need, at a time that you need them.
**Susan Daniels**: These people can help you prioritize your project and get people to engage in executing remember most of your subject matter experts have full time jobs right and you're just lending being lit a lot of your staff, particularly if you're working internal company projects.
**Susan Daniels**: Otherwise easy governance, people who can overseeing some of your vendors right to help you for him facilitate and collaborate on managing some of your vendors, so those were people would be on your governance as well.
**Susan Daniels**: I like this checklist because when i'm trying to build my project governance.
**Susan Daniels**: People want to know what are you asking me to commit to do right what would my role be and my responsibilities be if I was on your governance committee.
**Susan Daniels**: Well teta this slide helps you write that out for them right in a bullet list, this would be some of the roles and responsibilities, you know, this would be the responsibilities of the role.
**Susan Daniels**: it's extremely helpful and helping to recruit what you may see as a task question would be simply them listing some of these accountabilities and you, knowing that of that would be part of the roles and responsibilities of a project governance committee.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, good question coming in for him from Hema would anyone in procurement be worthwhile to have in project governance.
**Susan Daniels**: It would, in my opinion, the short answer is yes, in my opinion, if a significant portion of my resources are the project or through procurement.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh yes, I would want a as high up in the in the procurement department, as I could get to sit on my procurement my governance committee.
**Susan Daniels**: Just so that they're aware of the dynamics of my project and can be sensitive to what that might mean, as it ripples through the contracts, I have in play, so if i've got a lot of a procurement, yes or.
**Susan Daniels**: If I bring an issue to governance and it's relative to a procurement arrangement, I certainly would bring them into the room and make sure that they have a voice to counsel.
**Susan Daniels**: On and advise so they may not be full time Okay, but they would certainly have a voice they might not have a vote, but they would have a voice, so I would invite them on an as needed basis.
**Susan Daniels**: um.
**Susan Daniels**: So interesting question from john Susan this looks like the components of the project management plan subsidiary plans additional components, so how is this different from a pmt.
**Susan Daniels**: um they are their permission givers right there they're the ones, your governance committee.
**Susan Daniels**: are the ones that are overseeing every aspect of your master project management plan okay So yes, they have authority and oversight of every one of the subsidiary plans and components so that's why it resembles right, but this is about having.
**Susan Daniels**: authority over and influence over and.
**Susan Daniels**: have a voice over, even if they might not always have authority.
**Susan Daniels**: Thank you, the governance committee has the keys to the plp yes, it does.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um so.
**Susan Daniels**: Projects may have phases and very common phases, are the initiation phase, this is when we're doing the business case which you usually don't have any part of Okay, but it's still part of initiation for a project.
**Susan Daniels**: they're trying to go out and get the money and justify it, and then they start to.
**Susan Daniels**: write your position description or figure out who's the best project manager right that's all part of initiation.
**Susan Daniels**: They land on to the off you okay congratulations and then you start the Charter, so that might be the initiation phase and they they help you start identify some of the stakeholders that are going to be involved.
**Susan Daniels**: Then, when you start in the planning phase right, this is when we're developing all these different subsidiary plans and putting in all of these processes right and finding the accountable parties right.
**Susan Daniels**: that's the all the planning phase and then there's the execution phase and we'll start talking about execution on I don't think tomorrow until tomorrow afternoon.
**Susan Daniels**: On when we do the execution, then we start talking about on what does it take to close the project right that the wrapping it all up, so there are natural phases that projects can go through.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes you can you know start executing in some areas, while you're not quite you still planning others or you might be in the execution phase, but you're beginning to plan for the next.
**Susan Daniels**: iteration so things can overlap right, you can be executing your first thing from that while you're planning your second increment you just need to know there are different phases it all depends on.
**Susan Daniels**: How your project is organized another way that you might use phases in a project is pre event event post event, you know you might choose it there are phases of your project that can be set by the project manager.
**Susan Daniels**: One of the most important things that your arm your governance is going to help you do okay well i'm sorry, this is a rich slide so i'm going to let you have a moment to read it it's not fair for me to keep talking.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So this is just basically saying that um it's very common to bring in governance at each one of.
**Susan Daniels**: Like the conclusion of a phase, whether it's at the end of our initiation or planning or different increments or you're handing off at design, you know give getting permission to do build at the end of the bill get permission for funding to go do testing so governance often comes in.
**Susan Daniels**: Today, do the arm this.
**Susan Daniels**: The with authority, giving them the permission giving okay I at each one of the cook i'm sorry getting tired it's hard to talk this many hours in a row and Thomas getting a little tired.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: This is basically saying you're going to build natural phases into your project Sometimes these are pre designed by your organization, give me an example.
**Susan Daniels**: and sophisticated organizations, they have review committee meetings project review committee meetings.
**Susan Daniels**: On senior leadership meets and all projects have to give status reports and all projects are reviewed at you know, at a certain cadence.
**Susan Daniels**: And when those projects are reviewed sometimes they will shut down projects Okay, so that they can take the money and bail out projects that are in trouble, or they won't shut it down, but they will suspend it okay.
**Susan Daniels**: The reason that they put in these gates okay these phase gates is so that governance can stay in control of the spend is really about staying in control of the spend.
**Susan Daniels**: They allow you to get so far, and then you have to prove that you've gotten a good return on the money that you're making good progress and then they authorize you to go forward to the next phase Okay, these can be review phases and it's almost always about permission giving okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Sometimes, like I said, the Organization has pre existing cadences and pre existing differences.
**Susan Daniels**: Not all organizations that you may find yourself working in in your career are going to be really sophisticated.
**Susan Daniels**: You might be brought on as the project manager because of your certification and they're kind of looking for you to bring professional project management.
**Susan Daniels**: To the organization hey they've been kind of winging it are just kind of doing it ad hoc right.
**Susan Daniels**: The best they can, but don't really know best practices, so you may need to be able to set up a governance structure that.
**Susan Daniels**: Projects are reviewed by Okay, or you may need to set up a governance, where you report on a regular basis and get their advice and counsel, unfortunately, a lot of people look at reporting to governance as a scary thing.
**Susan Daniels**: It shouldn't be okay it shouldn't be at all, it should be, where you go in and you're honest here where things going well and here where things are not going well.
**Susan Daniels**: And I would like to get recommendations counsel and advice to help me get these sections back on track.
**Susan Daniels**: Well now, the people in the room, feel like there's a reason for them to be there and they can contribute from their perspective.
**Susan Daniels**: And they can leverage their network, and I mean it makes people feel good to be able to be the one.
**Susan Daniels**: To help you solve the problem hey to give that Why is advice to get something unstuck okay so lean into your governance meetings great common their trends transparent both feet.
**Susan Daniels**: On the ground, confident that you're doing your best, but as expected there's gonna be issues.
**Susan Daniels**: you're doing something that hasn't been done before it's a project if we could do it perfectly, it would probably be part of operations, and we would perfect the process.
**Susan Daniels**: The projects are unique deliverables unique product process service or result so, by definition, its new okay and you're the first one, trying to do this kind of project and create this kind of result.
**Susan Daniels**: They know that you're probably going to run into challenges, so be comfortable with coming in and saying hey I need support.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, all I can say say is that that was the attitude I walked into when I went to my governance meetings and, at the end of my career, the project that was my kind of final part was I integrated an entire city subsidiary into the mother company, do you think that was a complex project.
**Susan Daniels**: It had many work streams and, of course, there was places where things were integrating well and then there were places where they weren't integrating well Okay, and I just needed to come in and again advice and counsel and direction.
**Susan Daniels**: Setting up these intervals Okay, where you go to governance and they have the ability to give you additional resources authorized changes approve your plans, this is what that's all about.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: All right.
**Susan Daniels**: pause a moment and just check the chat.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i'm not seeing any specific questions just more sort of comments going on.
**Susan Daniels**: um Okay, please know, as I alluded earlier that some phases, are not as clean, you know as they were first we're going to.
**Susan Daniels**: collect requirements build a different design it then we're going to build it tested launch it, you know train.
**Susan Daniels**: Some of them are not as clean phases in a project, some of them can be happening concurrently are overlapping and that's when you take the perspective of initiate plan execute.
**Susan Daniels**: And you know, monitoring, control, we can can be happening throughout the whole thing so it's just a phases, are not always as clean and crisp as you might think they can be overlapping.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh we've got something that's flings it a lot better than I did so let's go ahead and look at another great video by in this waters.
**Susan Daniels**: I had to me.
**Susan Daniels**: Just about any project can be divided into phases phases of a project or logical divisions and the way the work is carried out.
**Susan Daniels**: The aim of dividing work in this way is to make managing the work easier, a simple project can include just one phase.
**Susan Daniels**: Take, for example, a project to install new desk phones for a group of employees, the project is straightforward and should be completed in just a day.
**Susan Daniels**: it's likely that this project will include only one phase phone installation a complex project like constructing a building needs a lot of time and planning.
A project of this scale contains multiple phases, for example, you may want to break up the project into seven phases design side preparation foundation superstructure electrical plumbing and painting, this makes it easier to break up all the work required for such a complex project.
phases in a project have several characteristics, they are sequential they each involve distinct work, the work that is done is have a distinct nature that is particular to that phase.
They repeat project management processes, these include processes in the initiating planning executing monitoring and controlling and closing process groups.
They each end with a handoff of work, the work done or the output of a phase is often referred to as a deliverable.
For example, a project may include a feasibility phase, the phase completes once a report on the projects feasibility is handed over to those responsible for the next phase.
Finally, they have natural end points at which the continued viability of a project is assessed the end of a phase is usually marked by a transfer or handoff of the work that was targeted for that phase.
The endpoint is an opportunity to assess the projects overall progress generally a phase ends, when a change of focus authorization for the next phase, or even the termination of the project occurs.
The end points are sometimes called phase exits phase gates or decision gates if they result in a project ending they're also called kill points.
The end of a phase and start of the next phase are good times to revisit your earlier decisions and assumptions.
You can tailor these to suit current demands or adapt to new information, how you plan and carry out the phases in a project should depend on the nature of the project, it will also depend on your own and your organization's preferred management approach.
For project life cycles that have more than one phase, the phase two phase relationships, maybe one of two types.
It phases, have a sequential relationship one phase is fully completed before the next phase starts This ensures that a project is carried out in a definite sequence, but it can add to the time it takes to complete a project.
phases may overlap with one phase starting before the previous phase finishes this can help and speeding up a project, however phases can't overlap, if one phase depends on accurate and complete information from a previous phase.
The project management methodology you choose for your project will often determine the structure of its phases, you may choose the methodology that has a predictive lifecycle also called a waterfall methodology for example.
A software development project using this approach would attempt to determine the time cost and scope requirements as early in the project lifecycle as possible.
Then the project would proceed through a series of sequential or overlapping phases.
Some projects have an iterative lifecycle scope is tentatively determined early in the project and then clarified as the project proceeds and more information becomes known.
Work in the early phases is carried out while later phases, are still in planning, this is called rolling wave planning, the focus is on planning work for the very near future.
There is also an incremental approach, that means that each phase or increments successfully adds to the functionality of the product, the end of each phase is marked by a completed deliverable.
For example, in a software development project, the coding and testing phases are repeated in increments as features are added to the product and deliver to the customer for review.
adaptive life cycles also called change driven or agile.
Are iterative and incremental but the phases are typically no longer than four weeks in duration This approach requires a high degree of customer involvement and is used for projects in which scope frequently changes.
**Susan Daniels**: More clarity than what I was able to provide earlier, but there was a good question that arose what's the relationship between phases and milestones.
**Susan Daniels**: So milestones are what are used in a schedule to mark theon of like a major body of work on kind of the end of maybe a work stream before a major handoff happens to another department, a major body of work, something that has.
**Susan Daniels**: Significant time and cost associated with it.
**Susan Daniels**: milestones you can in a phase of a of a project, you might have several milestones that are achieved several major deliverables are produced in this phase, I hope that adds clarification so phase, or a higher a higher level order of organization for mapping out your scope.
**Susan Daniels**: On can the phases be equated to the critical path on critical path is not something that's taken into consideration when i'm creating your phases it's really how you're dividing your entire scope.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay critical path is that series independent activities that you calculate to figure out what's your earliest arm finished date.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, those are the two the two good questions that came in and yes phases can overlap this it's common for because you're going to kind of see you can start planning that the one phase before the next phase in specially of um there's not a lot of dependency on handoffs.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So we've got about a half an hour left.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm Claudia asked, can I say that each phase has its deliverables yes, you can Okay, and if there are major bodies of work Okay, and not little deliverables, then you wouldn't have milestones as well in your phases.
**Susan Daniels**: Alright, so, in the interest of time i'm not going to talk through your appropriate governance for project.
**Susan Daniels**: One you've got the checklist on how to recruit people how to write that position description for their responsibilities, you understand your stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels**: Your sponsors are certainly on your governance, but there are other parties the end recipient of your result definitely would sit on the board.
**Susan Daniels**: good idea to have a procurement officer if you've got a lot of procurement contracts going on right because they can advise and counsel you as you go forward and then it kind of gets to who else do you think would really be beneficial to you, given what you're trying to accomplish.
**Susan Daniels**: It is appropriate.
**Susan Daniels**: If there is not an already existing in place formal you know governance over projects committee.
**Susan Daniels**: In place in your organization, it is appropriate for the project manager to nominate and recommend Okay, who they want as part of their governance and they would send that up as part of the plan in their resource management plan, who would I want to be part of my governance.
**Susan Daniels**: Remember that governance is an evolutionary process Okay, which means you can learn from your previous projects.
**Susan Daniels**: bring in your lessons learn, and you can also rotate people on and off your your governance committee as your project on moves through his phases.
**Susan Daniels**: At a certain point, some people may no longer have much to add all right, their value is kind of that windows closed so don't think it's one and done.
**Susan Daniels**: In your on in developing your governments your governance you, you may want to have a longer term view and when you write that proposal up line say in Phase one, this will be my governance Council, but when we get to phase now seven, this is, who, I think the players should be them right.
**Susan Daniels**: But you have a large voice in the ability to influence who's on your governance in most projects unless it's already pre existing and then you just follow.
**Susan Daniels**: The operating the organizational process assets of it's already built just follow along okay.
**Susan Daniels**: I got a question here, how would you add expert analysis cost to the budget, as you need the expert analysis to build the budget.
**Susan Daniels**: On.
**Susan Daniels**: that's a good question expert analysis would be internal Okay, you will use subject matter experts within your organization.
**Susan Daniels**: So that wouldn't be charged to to your project, this is you before the project has started to spend this is you still in initiating and planning.
**Susan Daniels**: That isn't charged off into the project, except your cost, this is you running around holding meetings with people okay you don't go out a house for expert analysis, most of the time.
**Susan Daniels**: If you need to that you got to pre negotiate like a in your management plan he here's my cost management plan i'm going to need some help, would you approve X amount for this consulting services that's how I go about it.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so.
**Susan Daniels**: The next segment, we got a half an hour and we're going to spend the whole final half hour that we have together really talking about the importance of how to close a project appropriately according to best practices and how to arm to transition your project to the recipient party.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so we're talking about closing we've done a whole lot of planning okay we're assuming you've done a whole lot of executing and now we've reached the point.
**Susan Daniels**: we're wrapping it up okay well a couple of things that we need to have is accepted deliverables under your traditional.
**Susan Daniels**: predictive life cycle projects and eat at the end of each iteration and agile you don't go to your sprint review your sprint review and and DEMO your arm your deliverables before they meet the definition of done so, we need those.
**Susan Daniels**: One of the.
**Susan Daniels**: key word here key word in project closing is archive Okay, there is a lot of archiving expectations.
**Susan Daniels**: In on the closing component, so if you had to remember one word relative to closing one key word when you're reading a scenario.
**Susan Daniels**: You would definitely want to pick up on the word archive Okay, because we're going to talk about the different things that they expect you to to archive to create an archive.
**Susan Daniels**: But you need to set the criteria of knowing when you're done right.
**Susan Daniels**: And there are different reasons, you would close a project.
**Susan Daniels**: will give you another moment to finish reading.
**Susan Daniels**: here's the key takeaway for project management professionals to get from this slide OK.
**Susan Daniels**: notice how for closing a project or phase there's one reason that's positive right the project or phase successfully met its completion objectives and then look at how many things have nothing to do with actually fully executing your project.
**Susan Daniels**: Projects no longer feasible there's no longer money on things have become too risky we've got the product that the Organization has changed direction okay there's things happening in the environment, like code that makes things just put all to a stall right.
**Susan Daniels**: The takeaway from this, ladies and gentleman, is that in the profession of project management, not all projects, see the finish line right and it is so common in our industry to have projects.
**Susan Daniels**: kind of just stop that don't take it personal just don't take it personal.
**Susan Daniels**: simply take a deep breath and go wow I was kind of enjoying that project, I wonder what i'm going to be doing next but just take that moment to go it's really common for the business to.
**Susan Daniels**: Work and manipulate and change up the what they're doing with their project dollar spends okay so.
**Susan Daniels**: They have to keep operations going, they have to keep operations funding okay and that's where the focus is that most projects are trying to augment enhance improve operations okay or execute products for external customers.
**Susan Daniels**: So there are reasons why customers change and what they want and that's all covered under the different kinds of contract changes that we can have okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But don't be surprised if you are working doing projects internal to companies, particularly large companies.
**Susan Daniels**: that you are going to be shifted from one project to another, they can stop projects and start other ones pick up ones that were stalled and resurrect them and get them going again, please never take it personal when your project.
**Susan Daniels**: doesn't get to see the finish line okay it's common.
**Susan Daniels**: Great point on me on me.
**Susan Daniels**: Susan Is this also laid out in the initial project Charter and then integration plan at the beginning.
**Susan Daniels**: I remember one of the questions which was what would cause an exit for this project I you get the.
**Susan Daniels**: The stakeholders, I mean the sponsors thinking, what would cause this to possibly be killed or stalled okay well, these are some of the reasons listed on the slide that you're looking at now Okay, these are the things that can cause you to exit strategy, I mean exit a project.
**Susan Daniels**: So yeah I got someone saying I got Raymond in chat going yeah he's going through it now right where they're they're stopping and starting projects through the monthly reviews it goes on like that.
**Susan Daniels**: So closing a project wherever it is right, even it's not the finish line is still required, let me reiterate.
**Susan Daniels**: Even if your product object is club, you know stops for anyone these reasons, you are still expected.
**Susan Daniels**: To close, it appropriately okay it doesn't have to hit that complete what law we got it done before you close it wherever you are, you have to wrap it up and do the appropriate documentation, including and notice this okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You need to be working very closely with your contractors and making sure that if you're going to close that contract with them that it is done.
**Susan Daniels**: ethically and legally okay you don't just call them up and now well you know they just full funding on the project, and I think this this contracts don you know.
**Susan Daniels**: can't do that Okay, he you need to get legal advice right and have legal counsel you on how this is going to close the contract legal will get the message legal understand what the goal is, which is to stop.
**Susan Daniels**: Any further work Okay, but there are steps to be addressed before you before you actually formally close contracts okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So that's that's the flag saying contract on projects can close, for a variety of reasons, and regardless of how they're closed, you have to make sure that they're done ethically legally right and all the archiving is done.
**Susan Daniels**: But let's stay back on the track that while lie, you know you're heading towards the finish line and you're really closing the project on a successful run okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Your project, one of the products Okay, one of the hallmarks or one of the triggers to start the clothes process the trigger for starting the clothes process is when you have accepted deliverables.
**Susan Daniels**: you've done the today, right here, it is here's the cake, the cookies the balloons right today, and you get accepted deliverables that's the trigger to start the closing process.
**Susan Daniels**: going to slow down here and ask you in your notes to remember this, there is a difference between verified deliverables and accepted deliverables.
**Susan Daniels**: Do not be confused between the two so i'm going to go over it again we introduced verified deliverables when we were doing quality control remember where.
**Susan Daniels**: You had all the specifications of what.
**Susan Daniels**: It measures and metrics for what qualified as a good deliverable Okay, and then you had in your plan how you were going to verify it who's going to do it under what measures, who do the report it to where did the results get posted as it gets shared that's all part of your quality plan.
**Susan Daniels**: So your team verifies deliverables your customer okay your end recipient.
**Susan Daniels**: is the one that accepts the deliverables Okay, you want accepted deliverables verified by us they're good they're good okay i'm good Okay, I hope they like it, I hope they accept it.
**Susan Daniels**: They should, I think they should and then you present and it's up to the customer internal or external customer to accept it okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Now.
**Susan Daniels**: Excuse me i'm sorry um.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: you're accepted criteria it's extremely I can't I can't emphasize this enough.
**Susan Daniels**: When you are negotiating on and writing your your your project plan you have to have, what is the acceptance criteria agreed to as part of your on your master project plan.
**Susan Daniels**: You sometimes it's mostly almost always, it is your objectives, your project has to be able to do such and such right on the so increase performance by this decrease costs by that much.
**Susan Daniels**: Improved customer service by this much whatever the objective is whatever measurable objective that you were brought on to be able to do that desired future state right.
**Susan Daniels**: you've worked really hard with lots of people to create this desired future state.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, it better be measurable right and we put those measures of success has project level project level objectives oh you've got acceptance criteria all along the way, your your arm verification criteria all along the way, but your acceptance criteria by your customer or your objectives.
**Susan Daniels**: Why am I, taking the time to go over this, because if you don't have a clear definition of what's acceptable and what's expected for your project at the end.
**Susan Daniels**: Then you are a part of a never ending project Okay, they can always expect a little bit more from you, and it could be disappointed it wasn't all that they were hoping for okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You can then turn to people that are less than happy when you declare done, you can say look, I met my project objectives now if you are looking for this to be more than it is.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll be more than glad to meet with you to start to collect requirements, and we can perhaps pursue funding for phase two high for the next phase, or the next iteration of the project, but for now i've met all of the objectives of this project.
**Susan Daniels**: You want a definition, you know of acceptance start with the end in mind, it will protect you if you take a project and you don't do a charter and you don't set the project objectives in a clear measurable way.
**Susan Daniels**: You can be on this project for years Okay, because you never know when you're done.
**Susan Daniels**: Because there's always more that could be done.
**Susan Daniels**: So you want to be able to cut it off when you've met those objectives.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So when you start to close one of the key things and it falls on you, is to make sure the final payments are done is part of the closing process.
**Susan Daniels**: Unfortunately, I regret to report that many project managers get pulled on to the next project before they get a chance to actually finish the one they're on right they start looking like they have capacity.
**Susan Daniels**: And suddenly they get a new project thrown on them and they're supposed to be doing.
Right.
**Susan Daniels**: You have your php or you will.
**Susan Daniels**: conduct yourself accordingly close projects before you, you know get pulled into the next one.
**Susan Daniels**: Making sure all of your vendors are paid, including their final hold back monies.
**Susan Daniels**: And that they're all a send Thank you notes to your vendors and you've got good working relationships with all of your vendors Okay, because you may need to knock on their door again right, want to have.
**Susan Daniels**: It where they open the door to go yeah hey glad to hear from you, I even as opposed to you know it took a hell of a long time to get my last payment to me right, you don't want to be that guy hey you want to make sure your payments are in place.
**Susan Daniels**: The other part of closing i've seen a couple of questions coming through so before I talk about knowledge management i'm going to scan my my chat off to the side.
**Susan Daniels**: let's see Susan.
**Susan Daniels**: Yes, i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: projects can be stopped her clothes, because of men and exit criteria which is um.
**Susan Daniels**: Whatever was pre agreed to in the on the Charter right, you can close the project when it meets that but exit criteria is more what would cause a project to be killed Okay, as opposed to.
**Susan Daniels**: What is the objectives of success.
**Susan Daniels**: What is the relationship between acceptance criteria and quality oh good question because those two are like two sides of the same coin, in many ways um.
**Susan Daniels**: Acceptance criteria is ultimately what, when what at the end you go to da here, it is, and you can prove you delivered what the whole project was about acceptance criteria is at the highest level of your.
**Susan Daniels**: of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: Quality measures and quality metrics are for each component okay that you're putting together.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, for each word package and component you're putting together to make deliverables Okay, is that helpful and each one of these quality measures and metrics are what are verified.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, before that work package is put together and having the deliverable is created Okay, so that deliverable can then meet the acceptance criteria it's a kind of an order you know, an order of magnitude where you are in your in your scope.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, what is the relationship a would passing user acceptance testing be classified as a verified deliverable um.
**Susan Daniels**: Yes, yes.
**Susan Daniels**: Yes, and what i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Susan what circumstance would a contract be closed before payment.
**Susan Daniels**: um you wouldn't be able to close the contract before the final payment is made not not legally right, you have to you have to finish on compensation and get that in place what I mean by i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Closing before the final the what circumstances would a contract be closed before payment not sure i'm tracking with you stephanie sorry rephrase that i'll try again if a project is killed his payments still made basically prorated or does it depend on the contract um.
**Susan Daniels**: It depends on the contract really how it was written right but.
**Susan Daniels**: A product that's for legal to answer and to interpret the contract terms that's that's really not your role.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, you get you get legal involved in that, and sometimes procurement officers well seasoned procurement officers can often handle it as well, but it's certainly not your role to to figure out the REP the ramifications on contracts, when your projects killed.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm Susan do pans have a dedicated team of folks to manage projects or is the team just ad hoc sneeze allocated different times throughout the project.
**Susan Daniels**: It seems the project manager has a lot of plates spinning and to be effective, should have a dedicated team.
**Susan Daniels**: The place spinning is right, you got a lot you're trying to keep going that's why I don't care about the Alpha numeric field, you know, on a screen that's why I have a configuration management system to manage all the details.
**Susan Daniels**: So there is no one right answer to your question Dave.
**Susan Daniels**: But most project managers, do not have a signed staff okay that are report directly to them.
**Susan Daniels**: If they're working internal projects they're only doing customers they're doing service to internal customers usually they just have subject matter experts that they borrow okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: As needed right and that's why you need influencers on your governance board that can lean on managers to get you the subject matter experts, you need.
**Susan Daniels**: But if you have external customers oftentimes project managers do have a dedicated set of teams.
**Susan Daniels**: TEAM members that help them execute those kinds of contracts or production of those kind of products for their customer, so it really depends on what kind of business domain, or what where you are in a business configuration, no one right answer there guy.
**Susan Daniels**: Quality is an internal process correct okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll answer um I need to move on, but stephanie on break i'll try to answer yeah okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So now we're moving on to our knowledge management, you have to make sure that.
**Susan Daniels**: Not only the payments are made right and that you've got it accepted the know we've got to sort of make sure that your recipients okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: When you're closing you want to do your lessons learned and you've heard this mentioned over and over and over throughout the last couple of days right the lessons learned is something that gets updated.
**Susan Daniels**: As your as you're moving through the project well now you're closing your project right.
**Susan Daniels**: This slide is really nice that kind of helps you categorize elements of your your lessons learned if you don't know how to organize it or you don't know what would go on it.
**Susan Daniels**: On basically start with issues, the kind of issues that arose during your project and what you did to solve it, because your issue log, as I said before.
**Susan Daniels**: is part of your performance reporting that you send up line to your senior leadership, so you may have 10 1215 different issue logs as you go through different reporting cycles.
**Susan Daniels**: And it's hard to collect them all up so your lessons learned is another document that you just keep building, as you go and it just keeps kind of scrolling down your word document, where you take your issue lock your commentary and pasted into your lessons learned right um.
**Susan Daniels**: But you also comment about what went well what you would recommend to do in the future okay it's not all negative it's also coaching and advice on what to keep doing on similar projects like this okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So you write your lessons learned Okay, and you need to make sure wherever you're such saving all of your project related documents that is well archived okay some.
**Susan Daniels**: Software platforms in like fortune 500 companies have the ability to archive and you set whether it's for a year or five years or 10 years you know, the ability to set.
**Susan Daniels**: How long, this is archived for well you you take your core documents and you make sure that they have been archived long term in more sophisticated organizations your project management office acronym P mo.
**Susan Daniels**: will have sort of a checklist of what you need to archive they want to know what each one of your plans for your sublet you know little.
**Susan Daniels**: Sub plans they're going to want to know what your change management plan was like they're going to want to know what's your on definitely have your risk register and risk strategies archived there's core documents that they would expect to be archived.
**Susan Daniels**: And they will show you were in the DEMO master organization of folders that they would want you to save it to.
**Susan Daniels**: So oftentimes, this is an OPA an organizational process assets it's a standard operating procedure you just follow it.
**Susan Daniels**: What happens if you don't have what have that right you're in a smaller organization then it's up to you.
**Susan Daniels**: To begin to bring the idea of a project management archive I know a project archive and it may be up to you to set up the first series of folders high, and I was said it by year really it's The easiest way to get things started set it by the year of the project.
**Susan Daniels**: And then basically set the sub folders that would that would happen and then basically say this is the way we archive create the template because you're bringing best practices into this organization.
**Susan Daniels**: It is value add that you bring and that's why they hired you right you've got your you understand world class best practices so bring them right if it doesn't exist set it up okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, almost at the end of the hour.
**Susan Daniels**: This is one more thing transitioning planning artifacts okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So what this is about is okay, so you got your today's meeting you got it all delivered and accepted right, and you know they're happy.
**Susan Daniels**: they're happy and they accepted what you've done and you've gotten to close your contracts and right your lessons learned and you've got your your things archive well, one of the things that you, you need to make sure that you have is how are you making sure that yeah they accepted.
**Susan Daniels**: The deliverable the Ted ah, the final result, but be sure to comment that you have in that closing part any sort of training documents or any sort of user manuals or.
**Susan Daniels**: Communication frameworks that have been set up for them, you have to make sure that all the transitioning.
**Susan Daniels**: requirements are awesome that okay so transitioning is part of closing and transitioning may have requirements that are that are involved okay.
**Susan Daniels**: It can be a whole training plan that has to start being executed Okay, once you have the.
**Susan Daniels**: It works all the screens have been built and all of them have been developed right and your focus group has said yes, this meets our expectations, yes, this is what we want, so you've gotten them verified.
**Susan Daniels**: And then it all works together and you say Okay, except this deliverable and then they can be trained.
**Susan Daniels**: Usually in batches.
**Susan Daniels**: So this is just saying party closing you may have still more work to do.
**Susan Daniels**: Transition readiness haha.
**Susan Daniels**: This is, this is a new transition planning and transition readiness.
**Susan Daniels**: wasn't in the sixth edition it's more in the seventh edition and it's saying hey guys it's not enough just to have it today.
**Susan Daniels**: Here, good luck hope it works for you all right, you know hope hope you're happy that you're here er and you're done on to the next project.
**Susan Daniels**: This is really making sure that you're leaving your end users hundred percent satisfied okay they're they're completely ready to gain the business value from what you're giving them.
**Susan Daniels**: that's what transition readiness is about are they completely prepared to gain the business value from what you're delivering them.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay we've reached the end of this um.
**Susan Daniels**: If you can indulge me i'm i'm going to go ahead and do the the the quite the mastery builder questions I know we have 129 that will go through through these just to look at them um you know what.
**Susan Daniels**: Well yeah i'm going to do it now.
**Susan Daniels**: This is a scenario that's going on, can you tell what kind of contract Okay, they may be using what kind of contract structure, and this is truly representative of the way that i'm exam questions may run here's a scenario.
**Susan Daniels**: Can you identify what's going on.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so I got a question scroll to what do we mean by see an IP thing.
**Susan Daniels**: cut.
**Susan Daniels**: Costs plus incentive fee.
**Susan Daniels**: Is a type of contract i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: fixed price with economic price adjustment.
**Susan Daniels**: You don't generally see on your contract types put in acronyms but one of the things that you may learn more about is the different types of cost reimbursement and the different types of.
**Susan Daniels**: fixed price contracts, and you can find that explained in more detail in the sixth edition under on plan con plan procurement okay process.
**Susan Daniels**: But most of you are right Okay, so the correct answer is cost reimbursement that's because he's passing along the cost right he's passing along the cost.
**Susan Daniels**: If the project was terminated early, why would the project manager insist, the team perform the clothes project or close Phase I mean we're done we go, we can just abandon it right, we never got to the finish line let's just leave it where it's at right.
**Susan Daniels**: Wrong right, regardless of the reason why it got closed.
**Susan Daniels**: Right, you still have to take it to the closing process, but what would be the reason.
**Susan Daniels**: I am seeing it coming through with on two answers, and I understand this, is it did not say pick two so you're really supposed to narrow it down to just one didn't tell you to pick two so which one's the best answer.
**Susan Daniels**: You are correct okay i'm i'm running a little over this is the last one, and I appreciate your indulgence in a multi phase project which of the following terms refers to a decision to continue with the next phase, or to end the project.
**Susan Daniels**: This goes back to the video that you saw.
**Susan Daniels**: and
**Susan Daniels**: In the interest of time i'm going to go ahead and give you the right answer it um it is kill point and phase gate go no go is sort of a shorthand jargon.
**Susan Daniels**: term that's very popular, but it is not pmi terminology kill point and phase gate or pmi terms okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So with That being said, we're going to kick off for our break we're going to resume again at 230 so thank you for your indulgence for a couple of minutes, I will stay on and.
**Susan Daniels**: On try to answer some questions that are in coming through the the chat, but I do to want to take on lunch break see you guys in a little while.